we've almost 500 next 2018 it's
understandable that you couldn't get to
them all so if you didn't see gcp
database migration services then stay
tuned because here's the revised
[Music]
migrating your on-premises databases to
the cloud is a fantastic way to reduce
costs improve reliability and expand
your scale but the process of moving
that data isn't always straightforward
which is why our teams here at Google
cloud have some best practices to share
dominic price walks you through the
three main stages of data and
infrastructure migration assessment
migration and validation each of which
have their own specific nuances let's
start with assessment where it's
important to first discover all the
information about your data including
what you're planning to move and what
dependencies are involved with that then
you need to learn about the capabilities
of the cloud platform services you're
moving to in order to understand feature
parity and performance at which time you
can finally determine the right path
forward for your migration now once you
have completed your assessment it's
critical to evaluate for each of your
data bases what my Croatian type you do
this includes looking at each data base
and asking questions like if you still
need it if it should be replaced by
another system rehearse it refactored
revised or even rebuilt this helps you
plan on exactly the type of work that
needs to be done for each of your data
bases now from a more practical
perspective it's important to ask
yourself whether or not your data base
can handle downtime during a my creation
process for example if you can stop
right store your existing database
export your data to a source like cloud
storage and then import into your new
data base then this is going to be a
less complicated and rather
straightforward process to speed up
offline my creation the talk touches on
a couple of performance Hex you can do
in short optimize the schema choose
powerful instances for import and
monitor brokers to adjust along the way
if you can't allow for downtime then
you'll need to rely on replication to
get the job done this is where you
replicate your data to the new database
and once the data is fully replicated
meaning the leg between the old and a
new database is minimal you can simply
do a
get you'll fail over towards a new
database with no or minimal downtime
link yard if you do a hit the
heterogeneous migration there are a
number of partner application that can
help you with the live my creations
once you have migrated it's finally time
for the validation step which first
includes ensuring that all the data has
come across properly and then validating
that your performance and cost
expectations are still accurate with
your new cloud enabled databases if
you're interested in more information
about migrating from Cassandra to cloud
big table or cloud spinner as well as a
create customer profile with many live
demos and how they accomplish database
migrations then check out the full talk
links as always or in the description
below and don't forget to subscribe to
the cloud YouTube channel for more necks
or wine content thank you for watching
you
[Music]